**Susan Daniels***: Welcome back everyone, so we are now in session one afternoon session, part two.
**Susan Daniels***: During this we are going to be covering let's and this session we're going to cover engage and support virtual teams and build shared understanding about the project.
**Susan Daniels***: or next breaks should occur somewhere between 445 and five o'clock.
**Susan Daniels***: So we've talked about empowering teams and this section is about virtual teams which is going deeper on where teams are how the way of work is changing and virtual teams are more prevailing now than ever before.
**Susan Daniels***: So our whole task has been dedicated to ensuring that project management professionals are aware of and insightful about how to manage and lead virtual teams.
**Susan Daniels***: there's been a lot written and a lot of material available to study best practices on how to work with virtual teams, but we're just going to touch on some of the most well recognized and agreed upon aspects.
**Susan Daniels***: So let's go ahead and talk about some of the things that if you are managing a team effectively, as you know, part of building and creating high performing teams that you are using collaboration technology.
**Susan Daniels***: And that you understand how to kind of get a temperature check or how to assess how engaged your team is do you just.
**Susan Daniels***: Take that Malays, on the other end as well that's just the way they are you know um are you assessing on an ongoing basis how engaged your virtual team resolved because it's very easy to get.
**Susan Daniels***: Isolated okay when you're working virtually which I think many of us can relate to.
**Susan Daniels***: And, of course, if you're doing virtual teams you're still going to need to update your project and your resource calendar okay.
**Susan Daniels***: tools that we use okay our arm basically our plan our communication plan communication tools and techniques.
**Susan Daniels***: will go deeper on communication on a later date, but we're going to touch on it here and then your project management powers which we most likely are not going to address today but it's.
**Susan Daniels***: it's a very interesting discussion when we get to it.
**Susan Daniels***: So we've touched on different kinds of collaboration technology, we talked about how do we share knowledge and what are some cloud based filing sources, you know platforms listed a few in the arm.
**Susan Daniels***: The the chat but what I think we need to know here is that if you're going to run a virtual team tools like webex teams slack.
**Susan Daniels***: zoom okay these cannot be foreign things to you Okay, you should be able to get on your corporations on.
**Susan Daniels***: Collaboration platform and being at least minimally proficient to be able to book a meeting facilitate a meeting and how to work, the technology.
**Susan Daniels***: it's becoming table stakes now or minimum requirements, these were things that only the upper levels of the company ever got to do on video conference I mean.
**Susan Daniels***: You are all of that, in a bag of potato chips if you were going to go to a video conference a couple of years ago.
**Susan Daniels***: Because that was a special room with you know special equipment and you're going to be talking to you know another part of the world.
**Susan Daniels***: It was a big deal now we've got grandchildren talking to their grandparents, you know with absolute ease and casualness on their on their devices so understanding collaboration technology is really gone from oh wow how exclusive to you need to basically be good at it by now okay.
**Susan Daniels***: um so one of the things that these tools, enable us to do is to have a common place to share information and to look at the same thing all at the same time, regardless of where we are in the world.
**Susan Daniels***: And some of the more sophisticated platforms, allow us to mark up and Edit the documents in real time multiple users on is sort of like switching who's going to the board right and going up and and presenting so understanding how to use these is is what it's all about now.
**Susan Daniels***: Again i'm seeing a checklist right so chat boards and task boards and knowledge repositories that's the cloud storage right.
**Susan Daniels***: video conferencing tools, these are all integrated now then they're not separate Apps that we jump between they're becoming integrated and that has made life a lot easier okay it's which is better now than it used to be okay, but it's still a minimum requirement.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so i'm just looking through the chat.
**Susan Daniels***: To see if there's any feedback.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm interested in common that says somehow it ultimately praise more work for those that are physically present.
**Susan Daniels***: um that might be true, but one of the things that I want to encourage is that if you are facilitating a meeting.
**Susan Daniels***: And you've got people coming in remote and there isn't video available okay there's just audio it's a conference call right.
**Susan Daniels***: um there should be someone that represents the on the collars so if a dialogues going on in the room and he's going hot and heavy and people aren't being polite and going.
**Susan Daniels***: This is Susan, I just wanted to tell you Jane that I think your idea has great merit i'd like to explore it further with you Jane Jane response, this is Jay thanks Susan let's set something up.
**Susan Daniels***: Your people when you've got people in the room and you've got people only on a call is extremely helpful for the people in the room to say who the heck is talking not everybody knows each other's voice right, so you should self identify every time you open your mouth.
**Susan Daniels***: Secondly, how does the one that is designated as the facilitator, or the representative for the callers.
**Susan Daniels***: Who would do something like this 18 I heard, I heard your response that you said to Joe but i'm not sure everyone on the call Dick is.
**Susan Daniels***: The microphones way down at the end of the table here Would you mind repeating that for those that are on the call.
**Susan Daniels***: And it just kind of slows the role, a little bit, but it makes everybody stay on page together so understanding how to facilitate and use collaboration technology and techniques is is.
**Susan Daniels***: Is a differentiator from one level of project management facilitation to another.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm seeing that depending on your industry there might be more demand for in person, you know feet on the ground, then there are virtual but hybrid is still very strong, even in industries that are classically require everyone to be present for example banking.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, people are just sharing what they're using okay um.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh that'd be great not only say what name, you are but say your name, but what department you're representing absolutely to help people who are listening in better understand.
**Susan Daniels***: This slide is really where the questions may come from Okay, what are the basic needs of a virtual team, and you need to know them clearly they they have to have shared goals, one thing that is often felt by.
**Susan Daniels***: Those that are remote is the sort of us and them mentality, the people that are on camp in that headquarters and the mother company or the antonym the headquarters, the main site.
**Susan Daniels***: And those working remote they feel like they're not in the loop they feel like they are in the know okay so being able to have them be in the know and clarify what their roles and responsibilities are is really important, let me elaborate a little further.
**Susan Daniels***: People join teams and they don't have the history of that team right they don't know the dynamics and sometimes they're not in a position to ask.
**Susan Daniels***: What does she do what does he do right they've been on the job for a week or two and they feel like maybe they can ask a whole lot of questions and how do you ask somebody else on your team so.
**Susan Daniels***: Like What do you do right some people aren't brave enough to do that.
**Susan Daniels***: that's where your table of organization comes through not your table, but your org chart comes in that onboarding PowerPoint comes in, but if you don't have that.
**Susan Daniels***: You need to be responsible as a team manager, to make sure that everyone understands their roles and responsibilities, what they mean here by shared goals.
**Susan Daniels***: And the emphasis here is instead of making the work on each person individually accountable for something, although that is important okay.
**Susan Daniels***: That the team shares a performance goal together that way, nobody can be ostracized or left isolated.
**Susan Daniels***: If they're not performing they're going to get pulled in right because the whole team has something at stake here, their whole overall score evaluation is going to be based on not just what they did.
**Susan Daniels***: You know individually well how the team performed overall right it's not good enough if susie got her work done two days early, but the whole team was late by two days hey what is susie do for four days.
**Susan Daniels***: The season gets done early the team goal has to be done on time, which means She then reaches out to who's struggling and seeing how they can help you want to set shared goals when there's a virtual team it forces, if you will, the dynamic of having to engage.
**Susan Daniels***: And, of course, the clear purpose is another way of saying, clear objectives or how they're going to be measured right.
**Susan Daniels***: So virtual team engagement.
**Susan Daniels***: When you're talking about engaging of teams, you have to understand their the need for transparency.
**Susan Daniels***: And one of the easiest ways to get transparency going is having people turn on their cameras.
**Susan Daniels***: yeah you might see their dog come through and you might see that they have their cat you know, in the window, or you might see you know some walls through right.
**Susan Daniels***: So be it, but they become more three dimensional people they become more than just a name on a piece of paper, a role or you know someone you don't have any sort of.
**Susan Daniels***: Whole perspective about so whenever possible when facilitating meetings lead by example turn on your camera.
**Susan Daniels***: to one of the things that happens when on.
**Susan Daniels***: Video when zoom meetings happen it's not everybody logs in at the same time right they always kind of got that awkward couple of first minutes when people are logging in and situated and getting going.
**Susan Daniels***: that's the perfect time to have team based conversations you know starting the work conversations talking about personal things like.
**Susan Daniels***: hey how was that wedding you went to last night, you know our last weekend was it everything you thought it would be or.
**Susan Daniels***: You like in your new car how's that vacation planning coming along when they get back tell us about your vacation.
**Susan Daniels***: Is your daughter ready to graduate you must be so excited get them engaged and talking about each other's personal lives that way they are again.
**Susan Daniels***: Real people with real lives and real issues going on, then everyone has a sense of who they're working with you want a sense of.
**Susan Daniels***: engagement and concern among your team members not just individual cogs entry created as if anybody could just be replaced in a drop of a hat, you know you don't carry anyway right you want to lean into them and you want your team members to lean in and learn about each other.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm just looking at the on the chat board.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, when you're managing a virtual team communication is foundational to success and you're going to be using the platform of your organization to on to manage the engagement.
**Susan Daniels***: But there's also the other tool and please don't forget one of the key tools for managing communication is that team Charter can anybody remember what goes in your team Charter can you guys put in scroll or list a couple of things that come to mind, for your team charter.
**Susan Daniels***: I just saw the expression go round.
**Susan Daniels***: In the chat and I just wanted to say that's pretty much what I was referencing but someone has to start it and set the norm, if you will, that the first couple of minutes is going to be kind of a go round what's new with you right.
**Susan Daniels***: And you get a chance to you know brag or boast or you know lament and and a home and complain right like I.
**Susan Daniels***: I woke up this morning that I had two flat tires you know that's how my day started I hate, well, it gives them something to talk about the next time right so when they come back on the next one hey did you get those tires situated.
**Susan Daniels***: Do the go round and said start with yourself hey here's what's new with me okay um but then after that get them used to be starting with someone else instead of just always being with you, but this at the norm, of what you're looking for is topics for that go round.
**Susan Daniels***: And you guys are right on the money when when it comes to what is in your team charter that's going to help you facilitate effective communications.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm in the agile world we also use retrospectives, which is when the team sits around and talks about what worked what didn't work and what can we do differently.
**Susan Daniels***: We also have this communication boards that we use to keep everyone accountable.
**Susan Daniels***: And this is just an introduction okay other parts of.
**Susan Daniels***: tools that we can use we talked about the stakeholder engagement night men.
**Susan Daniels***: matrix hi what's their power was their interest was their power was their influence Okay, you can have people that don't have much power but but can be very influential in their area.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so you can use those as well, it helps facilitate your communication and stakeholder engagement engagement.
**Susan Daniels***: um so when it comes to communication we have another component of your master project management plan that's capitals project management plan whoa.
**Susan Daniels***: The plan right well this master plan has sub components and in the sub components we've got a resource management plan we've got a communications plan right so.
**Susan Daniels***: What goes in your communications plan well.
**Susan Daniels***: Some of the things that we would see.
**Susan Daniels***: In our our Charter or team charter when are we going to have our meeting times right what is an agenda look like do we have a standardized agenda.
**Susan Daniels***: which by the way, every meeting you ever on call should have an agenda attached to the meeting invite.
**Susan Daniels***: Unless it's a reoccurring meeting and if you're booking reoccurring meetings you can call it placeholder right and call it placeholder for and then, whatever the name of the meeting is and in the notes go agenda will be uploaded you know before meeting convenes.
**Susan Daniels***: And then you can set your reoccurring meeting, but by the time meetings are are close like within 48 hours you definitely need to have your meeting agenda ready and included in your invite.
**Susan Daniels***: Because people often get double and triple booked and the only way they're going to know what is the best use of their time is to be able to look at your meeting agenda.
**Susan Daniels***: and your meeting agenda will include the who's invited what's the goals of the meeting what's going to be discussed okay and, fundamentally, what to anticipate for that meeting.
**Susan Daniels***: We can go cover that more when we get into um basically managing the work.
**Susan Daniels***: Your communication plan is going to also take into your performance management is going to say.
**Susan Daniels***: And this is where you capture who owes you what performance data information or report by what time okay how often who's accountable where's it stored right who has authority to update it so all of that's part of your communication plan.
**Susan Daniels***: And here's an interesting one prefer communication approaches for each person that you have as an on your stakeholder register, which would include your team members, because all TEAM members are stakeholders, not all stakeholders and TEAM members.
**Susan Daniels***: What is the preferred communication approach.
**Susan Daniels***: Some people think that.
**Susan Daniels***: They don't do voicemail they don't their email inbox is overloaded it's gotten spammed they barely check it right less told to.
**Susan Daniels***: And they prefer to do everything through text or a personal phone call you need to figure out how best to communicate with this with each one of your stakeholders everyone sort of has a preferred channel, if you will.
**Susan Daniels***: I have war stories horrible war stories by using the wrong communication channel to try to get my message delivered.
**Susan Daniels***: And couldn't get it through and couldn't get it through until it was crisis intervention time and if i've only known what their preference was I probably would have had the answer within about five minutes, but I didn't.
**Susan Daniels***: So take the time when you are getting to know your stakeholders to reach out and ask them what is their preferred communication.
**Susan Daniels***: do, how do I let you know I need you to be aware of something.
**Susan Daniels***: When it comes to yeah we've got the morning stand up meetings that's one way to get the message across, but you really want to look for ways to.
**Susan Daniels***: to continuously improve your communication plan, this is not a one and done document because people will tell you in no uncertain terms if they're not getting the information that they're expecting they're getting too much information or they can't find your inner information or.
**Susan Daniels***: Whatever complaint, they have people have a tendency to let you know so when you write your communication plan I published my first one is draft okay I kind of expect push back.
**Susan Daniels***: let's see.
**Susan Daniels***: There are people.
**Susan Daniels***: There are people who don't ever check emails yeah they're out there.
**Susan Daniels***: You got to reach them by text or you have to reach them in person or you have to book time on their calendar Okay, and then you can reach them um.
**Susan Daniels***: This one says we've always had primary alternate and tertiary communication plans for our virtual meetings excellent planning somebody a real project manager lots of contingency approaches.
**Susan Daniels***: Does it take a lot of extra time to write all this down and have it available, yes, but that's what you're paid for it to create these documents, so that at a moment's notice anybody, you can be pulled off the project you're on.
**Susan Daniels***: and put in someplace else and someone can will step right in behind you right who are the stakeholders, how do I communicate with them who's giving me walk when.
**Susan Daniels***: what's the best way to reach them your communication plan and your stakeholder register or some of the first documents that you'd complete.
**Susan Daniels***: Now that communication plan can take you a while to finish developing right because you got to get all your performance management plans figured out.
**Susan Daniels***: But you can start it pretty early now the way that I did it was i've had my stakeholder register and then I just built on a couple more rows into my arm to.
**Susan Daniels***: make it my communication plan, who gets what you know Sally gets this joke is that he's on these distribution list this.
**Susan Daniels***: This this is preferred communication channel, these are the meetings, he gets invited to I had different columns okay just add it onto my stakeholder register, then I could sort and collapse it as needed.
**Susan Daniels***: So managing virtual teams is.
**Susan Daniels***: Really, where it's at right now in project management in many ways.
**Susan Daniels***: I would be surprised any project can get done today without having some virtual TEAM members.
**Susan Daniels***: It would have to be a pretty small project done only internally to your division right or within your own.
**Susan Daniels***: area, the company Maybe you can get away with not having a virtual Member, but if you start doing any sort of cross division across department collaboration yeah you're gonna start getting virtual rather rapidly.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, just looking at the chat.
**Susan Daniels***: yeah there was a good good comment, just because you sent the email doesn't mean is received, and you can set read receipt um but if they don't if they're not reading it, you need to find an alternative channel.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: yep just building out your communication from on the basis of your stakeholder register is pretty straightforward okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So we're still trying to arm to manage stakeholders on virtual teams.
**Susan Daniels***: And we're doing that, through communication, so what I will not.
**Susan Daniels***: Talk about here is having that shared calendar and knowing that meetings are time boxed okay.
**Susan Daniels***: When you go to to set up your project, to the extent possible, you want to figure out who you want to meet you know what kind of meetings you need to have whether you got an agenda item for not or not.
**Susan Daniels***: You may need to know that it can get worked at the next meeting right it's on the books so reoccurring meetings are a project managers best friend.
**Susan Daniels***: But they need to be on a very steady cadence Okay, and you may invite 10 people or six people to this meeting, and you may get pushed back that not everyone can come every time.
**Susan Daniels***: that's okay it's on the books, people will know when they're convening back so that they can work to issue.
**Susan Daniels***: create as many standing meetings as you think your project needs, you can always cancel them.
**Susan Daniels***: that's never a problem to cancel a meeting and people get more time back on their schedule, but the deeper and the faster and the harder your projects running.
**Susan Daniels***: Because I know we're still missing initiation we're still just kind of easing into developing our team and starting the work, but as soon as you figure out what kind of cadence meetings you need book them okay get them on the books.
**Susan Daniels***: This one reiterate, if you have a time box, you only have an hour then you've got to be very judicious about how you're going to use that hour, which means you need very clear agendas and objectives for each meeting and you might have more to do than you have time.
**Susan Daniels***: it's a very um.
**Susan Daniels***: I don't know the word for it i'll go with not good it's not good to overpack a meeting where you really only have time to talk about three topics effectively right and then have a few minutes to wrap up and do follow ups and next steps.
**Susan Daniels***: If you try to fit five or six items into that meeting people are going to walk out and feel like Well, no, I lot got done okay.
**Susan Daniels***: did a lot of talking but we really kind of didn't solve anything right you just kind of blew through a bunch of acknowledgement of problems.
**Susan Daniels***: don't overpack you're meeting people won't get mad if you let out early Okay, but they will if they feel like they spent an hour and they didn't really accomplish anything so do set clear agendas and can and.
**Susan Daniels***: objectives, if you will.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm seeing a good book on.
**Susan Daniels***: Call Newport COM okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Our time box meetings reoccurring on tight box simply means that.
**Susan Daniels***: it's a it's an expected amount of time, for example, your daily stand ups should be about 15 minutes your.
**Susan Daniels***: retrospectives might be an hour for each week of work that was in your sprint Okay, there are certain standard times in agile that are considered the norm, or the time box for these different meetings, whether it's a sprint review or retrospective or daily stand up.
**Susan Daniels***: On grooming your backlog.
**Susan Daniels***: Was same thing in traditional you need to have a standard amount that makes this sort of project meetings, going to be, and if you do a daily stand up.
**Susan Daniels***: Fine, but don't make it a variable amount of time people know this takes 15 minutes right, and they can manage and plan accordingly, so that's what they're saying to be highly effective get it on the calendar and be consistent in your cadence and in your time allotment.
**Susan Daniels***: When you're managing virtual teams you're going to have to do some degree of variance analysis right as a team works produces various okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Is the team estimating their work accurately is are they estimating that level of effort of their work, accurately.
**Susan Daniels***: Are we finding significant variants that they're overestimating how long is going to take, and we still got two or three days left in the cadence right in this sprint.
**Susan Daniels***: or before deliverables do, and you don't want that work to just stretch out right because people will stretch it out if given the opportunity.
**Susan Daniels***: You want to really have a real sense of their pace, because that's the goal we're trying to get a pace going of how much work can this team do any an interval what's realistic right.
**Susan Daniels***: We may have to start out with optimistic most likely and pessimistic estimates until we can get really where we've got a sense of harm trend line, and then we can move to the most likely.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, if it meaning speaking it starts with let me piggyback on that with with what was just said, or to echo what was said then, you have no purpose or reason is speaking um.
**Susan Daniels***: yeah sometimes piggybacking on on a topic is somebody who just wants to work their own personal issue okay and it's not part of the agenda of focus for the day then they're seeing it right.
**Susan Daniels***: As a meeting facilitator, you can simply say, I can see you feel strongly about that and I appreciate you, bringing it up as a topic, we need to address.
**Susan Daniels***: But I want to respect everyone's time today and i'm going to capture that for our next meeting, but let me work that with you one on one you know offline.
**Susan Daniels***: So, Joe and back to jail you go, you were saying about the topic right you innocence acknowledge that they have something they care about you, you will.
**Susan Daniels***: bring it to the whole meeting, if necessary, to want to work at one on one with them first right so is if they're just trying to bring in a whole new topic.
**Susan Daniels***: dumb but if they are trying to add clarification to whatever the topic is or given example of the topic discussion that's different it's just, then I came in here and we're having one of our meetings I really care about what I care about and I just want to start talking about it now.
**Susan Daniels***: That you need to be able to put into a parking lot in table it.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh, another one is right.
**Susan Daniels***: canceling the meeting is um even if you meet for only one topic you still hold it canceling consistently yeah basically says, you probably didn't need the meeting in the first place, and you need to reevaluate I agree.
**Susan Daniels***: If you call a meeting you probably had a real good reason why these needed to happen right, I agree with you.
**Susan Daniels***: Another thing is, if you find yourself, not having enough to fill a meeting, then you know enough issues to work, maybe you need to change your cadence maybe it doesn't need to be as frequently as you thought it was.
**Susan Daniels***: You originally thought.
**Susan Daniels***: um.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: I before we're still talking about meetings here i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: At the end of every meeting you should have time on your agenda that basically says next steps and follow ups.
**Susan Daniels***: And this is where everyone goes around the table and and says out loud what they captured as their next step, or as their follow up Mike and.
**Susan Daniels***: Trust me people will clarify for each other, oh no I was really asking you for this okay or.
**Susan Daniels***: hey wait a minute didn't you agree that you were going to send me that right, you know and it oh yeah yeah right so it's sort of that accountability.
**Susan Daniels***: and verification and you have accurate next steps and follow ups your scribe for the meeting captures those and you're pretty much halfway to having your minutes done and.
**Susan Daniels***: So there is some best practices for.
**Susan Daniels***: Virtual teams.
**Susan Daniels***: I can't emphasize enough that pmi once you to set these up where they have shared commitments that you're not managing the team.
**Susan Daniels***: Only individual by individual, but they all have something in steak or at risk together okay that it's on they're all accountable, not just Oh well, I did my cart you know I don't see why you're giving me any problems right.
**Susan Daniels***: everybody's got to have a sense of ownership of the end result.
**Susan Daniels***: they're all in it together is another way to put it okay emphasize i'm team goals of our individual performance, one of the best practices for for virtual teams.
**Susan Daniels***: So, in the next few minutes before we go on break we're going to touch on build a shared understanding about a project and we're going to make some progress in that direction.
**Susan Daniels***: We have now, in essence, concluded in the pmi curriculum for the tmp exam prep course lesson, one which was about build a high performing team okay so we've concluded that, but we are now moving into lesson two, which is in the process domain and it's about.
**Susan Daniels***: starting the work okay so we're going to start the work and the first thing we need to do is build a shared understanding about what is this project that you're asking me to lead right that i'm responsible for.
**Susan Daniels***: So one of the things that we we ultimately will produce is a clear vision of expectations on if you're using xp programming or extreme programming is called the.
**Susan Daniels***: xp metaphor, which would in something you would say something along the lines well when it's done is gonna be like this and they might put together some known images in the world, but they put them together and saying this is what we're building is new it's like this.
**Susan Daniels***: will touch on what the product box exercises are when we go deep into agile, on Friday, but it's an exercise to help you set vision and build common understanding.
**Susan Daniels***: Over the next few minutes we're going to talk about charters project plans kickoff meetings again the value brainstorming and T shaped scales.
**Susan Daniels***: i'll pause a moment let you read the slide.
**Susan Daniels***: there's an interesting point in the chat by David seems to go against racy chart for everyone to be accountable hmm okay so racy typically is tied to a task Okay, are a smaller.
**Susan Daniels***: assignment The sub component, if you will, a bigger deliverables so responsible people work on task and then there's an accountable person for the overarching deliverable.
**Susan Daniels***: So if you have a team that is responsible okay that's been assigned will use the word aside, if you have a team that's been assigned to produce these deliverables Okay, well, it may be that the races racy is that susie Joe Tina Louise and one.
**Susan Daniels***: All have different responsibilities for their, for their part, but they're all they all report to the person tag to be accountable for that particular deliverable might be let's use.
**Susan Daniels***: Jose so Jose would work with the people that are responsible, but he's accountable for seeing it all come together.
**Susan Daniels***: But what's been assigned for the team for that that time period is maybe three or four or five deliverables once got one louise's got one Josephine they all have different we have different deliverables that are due during that week.
**Susan Daniels***: How you hold the whole team accountable is that the whole team score for that week right.
**Susan Daniels***: will be based on the they get 6070 8090 100% of it done right did they get all of it done.
**Susan Daniels***: So that they're all in it together stop when they're done with their work, they can go help someone else Okay, who may still be struggling to get something done on time.
**Susan Daniels***: So that's it's how you can articulate who's responsible who's accountable, but you hold the whole virtual team okay ah there scored or appraised or their performance is evaluated.
**Susan Daniels***: As getting it all done, I hope, that's helpful.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: When you do the project conversion.
**Susan Daniels***: oftentimes when you're tagged to do a project i'm the person who is telling you tag your at your the project manager.
**Susan Daniels***: On has a view of this project thing not spent hours developing it researching and finding out what are the best alternatives, and what are all the requirements at any sort of detailed level Okay, they are.
**Susan Daniels***: Trying to help the organization get from its current state, to a desired future state.
**Susan Daniels***: And they are better at describing for you what the desired future state is that they're trying to achieve, and why okay why it's important does it increase customer satisfaction.
**Susan Daniels***: Does it lower expenses, does it increase revenue is it an efficiency improvement, they will tell you what they're trying to do, and it kind of how they're going to measure success for this desired future state.
**Susan Daniels***: Your job is to go from there to begin to not only understand what they want Okay, and the why they want it.
**Susan Daniels***: It becomes your job, and the project Charter and the project management plan to figure out how to do it OK, so the what and the why usually comes down to you Okay, and it is your jump off point.
**Susan Daniels***: um So these are often developed ahead of time before you're brought to the table, because that's how they got the money to support the project in the first place, they sold a business case of how the benefit would be to the company.
**Susan Daniels***: If we invest in this project, what is the benefit cost savings revenue customer satisfaction, etc.
**Susan Daniels***: Part of this is found in their vision or in a business case.
**Susan Daniels***: They may have an idea of what the solution would entail Okay, but not always, they can describe components of it, but nothing in great detail okay.
**Susan Daniels***: And some of the things that will include is how it differentiates from the competitors or what some of the key benefits or features are going to be things that they know and can see today.
**Susan Daniels***: But as you go out building your plan and and working in mirabelle come to light.
**Susan Daniels***: So, once you had that conversation with them, and he began to understand the what they want to the to the extent they can describe it, and why they wanted the benefits they expect to get from this investment Okay, then they bring you in to write the project charter.
**Susan Daniels***: This is your document that authorizes you empowers you to go forth and build this project okay your project Charter is a document that authorizes us the project manager it in formalizes and initiate the project.
**Susan Daniels***: There are project manager project charter templates available out there, but which you'll see as the primary components are listed here okay.
**Susan Daniels***: You can be asked on the test Okay, when you see a whole assortment of different things Okay, they may ask you what does this have to do with what document what product, what are you producing right if you have these elements identified.
**Susan Daniels***: I want you to think of the project Charter as a pre designed conversation template.
**Susan Daniels***: When you come into the meeting and you've been told that toobin you're starting a new project congratulations, you should come in hand to that meeting.
**Susan Daniels***: Right, with a project charter template so you start out listening, so this is our vision, and this is what they want to achieve and you listen and you listen right, but then it's time to start to interpolate that or two.
**Susan Daniels***: interpret interpret that into how do we make this concrete and literal, how do we actually do this.
**Susan Daniels***: So you're going to take what you hear and you're going to start asking questions.
**Susan Daniels***: They they might tell you some of the High Level requirements, some of the benefits or features that they want right they can give you the High Level project description right what is supposed to do right and the benefits.
**Susan Daniels***: But you want to talk about the boundaries, you want to talk about what is it not, what will what it won't do.
**Susan Daniels***: What divisions or customer bases or product lines it won't involve what geographic office locations won't be involved right you want to set what it.
**Susan Daniels***: is and what it isn't from the beginning to extent that you can suggest asking that question what are some of the boundaries of what it's not going to include leads to an interesting conversation.
**Susan Daniels***: Then you want to talk about risks, so this sounds like an interesting and challenging work and I appreciate the opportunity to do it, you say.
**Susan Daniels***: But, can you tell me from your point of view, what are the major risks I should be concerned about I can think of a couple, but I want to know what you're worried about.
**Susan Daniels***: And voila.
**Susan Daniels***: They start telling you all the reasons that you should be concerned and what mostly they're concerned about and that's the one to keep the eye on right because they're your sponsor.
**Susan Daniels***: that's the stuff that can kill your project, but you don't know unless you ask what they are losing sleep over.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, now the next thing is you typically ask is, can you tell me in your mind's eye, how you see this unfolding, you talked about what you want, and the features that you want, but how do you see this.
**Susan Daniels***: happening, some of the milestones and you may have one idea on how you're going to do this project and they may have a completely different.
**Susan Daniels***: They can tell you how they want you to organize the work, how they see it being most logically organized and unfolding if you don't know.
**Susan Daniels***: If you mean if you don't ask you don't know and you can start out what you think is a great plan, and when you show them their first draft of their project plan and it doesn't look anything like what they were expecting.
**Susan Daniels***: Now you're back you're back of way up okay so it's important during the Charter to try to figure out in gain agreement on what the milestones of this project are going to be, not the details, not the major components.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay pre approved financial resources yeah you want to talk about the money.
**Susan Daniels***: Do they have a general you know top dollar amount that they're going to authorize do they already gained approval for funding, yes, they have, or else they wouldn't have engaged you.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so there's going to be amount of funding in mind okay now some some sponsors are pretty cagey and they'll go yeah we have a number in mind, but i'm more interested in seeing what you come up with.
**Susan Daniels***: Right now, their words they're not going to tell you, and i'm at this point, you go well let's let's try to size it.
**Susan Daniels***: And I would round it, you know to like the nearest hundred thousand if it's a moderate sized project if you find it to be a medium or.
**Susan Daniels***: Larger you can find what increment you think is a good cut often nearest quarter million half million million ballpark it you want to try to get at least a ballpark of what they find acceptable.
**Susan Daniels***: If you come in below what they're thinking they're going to love it if you come in and above what they were thinking they'll let you know.
**Susan Daniels***: But it's instead of wasting your time on on that you might as well just try to get as close as you can to what they think is the range that this this project will come in.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay that'll let you know what kind of talent, you can go out and afford they'll let you know what kind of consulting services or vendor services, you might be able to bring in right.
**Susan Daniels***: You need to have a sense of it before you leave the room, or else you won't be able to get very far in your planning a building a high performing team.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay project stakeholder register, this can usually happen in more detail and a couple of passes, but I usually ask the question okay there's going to be a lot of stakeholders involved in this project that's pretty clear who are you most concerned about.
**Susan Daniels***: Right i've asked him about risks now i'm asking them to name them right who are they.
**Susan Daniels***: And this is when you find out that there are people that are going to care about this project.
**Susan Daniels***: That you might not even know they existed in the company, but you're going to know about them now, because your sponsor is worried about keeping that person engaged just the way they want them engaged.
**Susan Daniels***: So you start asking about stakeholders, you can always augment that stakeholder register and future passes, but it is part of the first conversation okay.
**Susan Daniels***: um project approval requirements.
**Susan Daniels***: Who has authority okay in this project, and what authorities do you have I can who do I have to get signatures from and for what and what can I sign on my own authority.
**Susan Daniels***: um, this is an important conversation you've already had a really robust dialogue with them and their understanding you're leaning in and you're very much asking the right questions.
**Susan Daniels***: they're going to be much more supportive giving you authorities to exercise to get this project moving it at this point so go ahead and include it now, who do I need to get approvals from and what approvals, can I have, and then the last question is generally.
**Susan Daniels***: What, how do we define success Okay, how do we ultimately define success which can be part of your project objectives but also.
**Susan Daniels***: What could happen that would cause us to kill the project.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, what kill this project.
**Susan Daniels***: So this is some items that are on your mouth your project charter hey and being very familiar with using the project charters is sort of the the hallmark of a project management professional coming in, prepared to have that scripting conversation with your sponsors.
**Susan Daniels***: oftentimes there's not enough time to do the entire project draft in one meeting so you then capture what you learned.
**Susan Daniels***: loaded into your template and send it back upstairs or wherever it is you send it and go i've taken a first draft Okay, please review revise and return with your comments okay and they'll see that you need to continue the dialogue and then you'll usually have your second round discussion.
**Susan Daniels***: And then I stop here and look for questions.
**Susan Daniels***: On.
**Susan Daniels***: hope so, do you follow their plan the sponsor on.
**Susan Daniels***: If it's directionally correct, I mean you don't know yet whether it's directionally correct you've not gone out and collected all the requirements on you've not really talked to anybody, but this one person which you're looking for or small group of people that are your sponsors um.
**Susan Daniels***: But you want to know what they're thinking you want to know what they were anticipating even if you come back and go well, based upon all the requirements that i've collected to get the organization.
**Susan Daniels***: From the current state to the desired future state, we may need to look at a different approach i'm bringing this to your attention for a decision.
**Susan Daniels***: You know, then you kind of know you're walking in with like this is what you're expecting, but this is what I think you need to be aware of, so no you don't have to follow it.
**Susan Daniels***: But i've rarely not been given good good advice, these people got to their position for good cause, and they generally know what they what's necessary so it's very helpful to ask, because you don't always have to the most of time you will.
**Susan Daniels***: Is this one call or a process of different meanings it's totally several meetings it's not enough to it's too much dialogue for generally one one hour call.
**Susan Daniels***: Yes, you do very much want to list arrange for money.
**Susan Daniels***: Is the project charter contractually binding or running estimate to be reviewed periodically.
**Susan Daniels***: Excellent question on Andrew it is generally once it is been filled out it's signed by both parties, because this giving you authorities is defined.
**Susan Daniels***: Excuse me it's defining the objectives of your project how you're going to measure success, I mean it's got some elements in it that you want locked in right, this is what you told me to go forth and do Okay, and you have them sign it.
**Susan Daniels***: And then that is your sort of authorization, you know from on high so when you start pulling people into meetings to start to your plan they're going to go so.
**Susan Daniels***: um who are you, and what are you trying to do, oh, let me send you a copy of my Charter in and they see who was signed by what the project is all about it's sort of your calling card it's one and done now, once you.
**Susan Daniels***: start building the rest of your project management plan, then that becomes your baseline that becomes what you're held accountable to Okay, but until you can build your whole project management plan is your project charter that is your driving force, it is your direction.
**Susan Daniels***: I see a few pitfalls here sponsors cannot articulate well the what and the why.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm which and sponsors are not communicate well through the organization your authority that's what the project Charter does for you, it it it.
**Susan Daniels***: It almost is the cause of needing to get clear Okay, it is the driver of needing to be clear Okay, a PM P uses charters.
**Susan Daniels***: And that's what we do and we don't really start projects traditional projects without charters and so some heavy lifting goes on during those first few conversations to nail that down.
**Susan Daniels***: and getting your authority articulated and signed off on, then, is you might not need a good communicator sponsor okay.
**Susan Daniels***: But you've got it in writing, you have the authority to get outside temp staff, you have authority to book a war room, you have authority to have access to testing environments whatever authorities that you know i've been authorized by the Charter and that's how you solve that problem.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, I need to pick up the pace, a little bit sorry.
**Susan Daniels***: So the next thing that you have is your project overview statement.
**Susan Daniels***: So your project overview statement is really meant to be brief and clear.
**Susan Daniels***: um you want to basically have a way in a paragraph or so no more than a third of a page to articulate what is saying here what you're trying to achieve the problem you're trying to solve or the opportunity you're trying to exploit and how you're going to measure success okay.
**Susan Daniels***: It is sort of your elevator speech if somebody said so what you're working on lately me.
**Susan Daniels***: And you would say blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah what am I objectives, what am I trying to solve, and we all know, we succeed when we do this right and you want to be able to distill your charter down into that project overview statement why.
**Susan Daniels***: Because nobody is going to really have the appetite to read about all the risks and the milestones and what is not when sometimes in your project overview statement you include what it's not if there's political reasons to do so.
**Susan Daniels***: But that helps you then kick off your project it's not the entire charter people only need sort of that opening orientation of what they're being invited to.
**Susan Daniels***: It also goes on a lot of your performance reports to orientate your leadership, oh yeah that project, I remember now and it was that cover sheet high overview statement that you use.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Is this is the project Charter, the same as a statement of work.
**Susan Daniels***: It depends on where you are at the table, if you are internal to an organization your project charter is used okay internally inside an organization.
**Susan Daniels***: If you are external to an organization and you are perhaps being contracted or vendors right and you're working as a vendor.
**Susan Daniels***: To support a project going on inside a project inside an organization, then no that's you don't use charges charters externally i'm sorry i've been talking nonstop for hours tongues a little tired.
**Susan Daniels***: Tartar is internal use statements of work are generally, what are used for external communications and, yes, it has a lot of the same elements and it is the same conversation to really understand the ask, so you are correct okay.
**Susan Daniels***: You can know i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: memoranda vendors understanding statements of understanding statement of work is statement of work is generally a component of the contract itself.
**Susan Daniels***: I would consider the Charter and the Memorandum of Understanding.
**Susan Daniels***: or a statement of understanding, to be a closer tie Okay, I would consider the project plan the internal and the statement of work, the specific you know plan of action that has to be executed.
**Susan Daniels***: per the contract to be that statement of work so once the plan and the statement of work once the Charter and the Memorandum of Understanding I hope that's helpful.
**Susan Daniels***: Thank you very much for letting me know i'm keeping you engaged so it's a long run Okay, so what we have in the next couple of slides is we're going to talk about really not yet, but we'll be talking about what kind of methodology we think this project is going to need well.
**Susan Daniels***: And then we'll talk later before we close out tonight, what kind of life cycle your projects going to need.
**Susan Daniels***: So some of the first things you take into consideration Is this something I can plan the work, work to plan and just deliver I mean, is it pretty doggone clear what's expected how to do it.
**Susan Daniels***: Not so much, but what is expected pretty clear division right, then I may want to take somewhat of a traditional approach.
**Susan Daniels***: If i've got components of it that have to kind of be worked on and see what was really going to work what's really going to fit, what is the actual ask, then I may have a component of agile.
**Susan Daniels***: And when are the whole thing to be agile with kind of finding our answer as we go that's the more agile reflective responsive.
**Susan Daniels***: project management methodology Then again, you might have a head of hybrid where some things are completely clear i'll just plan it out work my plan and some parts i'm going to be running on an agile and you haven't hybrid.
**Susan Daniels***: So there is no one right answer that is consistent and project management, it always depends on the project Okay, and what you think is the best way to get it done.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so i'm gonna i'm going to take us through on kickoff meeting yeah.
**Susan Daniels***: i'll tell you what why don't we why don't we stop here okay let's take a 10 minute break and we'll reconvene at five o'clock see in a couple of minutes as we've been at this for about an hour See you in about 10 minutes.